Okay, so the sandbox is where we
are allowed to save information.
Let's look at those three
subfolders we mentioned earlier.
Documents, this is where you
save important information.
iTunes will make backups of this folder,
and
the OS will never delete its contents.
Caches, this is for temporary info.
iTunes and iCloud will never
make a backup of its content.
Library is generally for any files
you don't want exposed to the user.
We don't need to worry
about this folder for now,
but in case you were curious,
that's what it is there for.
The rule of thumb is,
important stuff goes into Documents.
Things that won't be
necessary in the future or
are easy to recreate
should go into Caches.
In order to save something in
the sandbox, we need to do two things.
First, find where the folder
is within the sandbox and
then write to a file within that folder.
To achieve this, we will use the
following classes, NSFileManager to get
the path to the folder within
the sandbox, and then String to write or
read text files, or NSData to write or
read by binary files.
Enough talk, let's move to Xcode and
write some code.